now speaking of the good
transnational elites there is really
really good news
coming out
of the episcopacy coming out of the
catholic hierarchy there isn't a lot of
good news these days that comes out of
the catholic hierarchy very often you
will see bishops
or even the pope say things that seem so
contradictory to the faith or do things
that are contradictory to tradition or
the faith but
we got a good one we got a good one
right at the end of last week
archbishop cora de leone who is the
archbishop of san francisco
has officially barred nancy pelosi from
holy communion
we've got the letter here from
archbishop bishop cor de leone saying
that nancy pelosi
is
advocating for abortion this is
a grave problem and this is creating
scandal and she is she is imperiling her
own soul and and he's tried to deal with
her personally he's tried to speak to
her personally he doesn't hear back and
so he says i am hereby notifying you
that you are not to present yourself for
holy communion and should you do so you
are not to be admitted to holy communion
until such time as you publicly
repudiate your advocacy for the
legitimacy of abortion and confess and
receive absolution of this grave sin in
the sacrament of penance please know
that i stand ready to continue our
conversation at any time and will
continue to offer up prayer and fasting
for you now for people who do not know
exactly what all of this means which
includes non-catholics certainly but a
lot of catholics too don't quite
understand what this means
according to the catholic faith it is
the bishop's obligation to do this this
is not just a punishment
to to punish nancy pelosi for her
support of abortion
this is not just some arbitrary caprice
of the archbishop because he doesn't
like abortion but other bishops do like
abortion
it is
the obligation it is an act of mercy of
the bishop here to prevent nancy pelosi
from receiving communion because the
catholic church believes that if you
receive communion when you are not in a
state of grace if you receive communion
if you are in a state of grave mortal
sin you are eating your own damnation
you are you are further sinning by doing
that and so the shepherd leading his
flock has a responsibility and an
obligation to say no do not do this go
to penance
because this issue that we're talking
about here life this issue of abortion
is a non-negotiable issue there there is
not
any such thing as catholics for choice
or catholics for abortion right that's
not possible it is just ontologically
not possible the catholic church is
entirely opposed to abortion the
catholic church cannot change its
position on abortion it is not if a pope
came in one day and said we're for
abortion now he would not be able to do
that that is not a possible thing and so
it is
it is in the interest of nancy pelosi
and her immortal soul and certainly the
rest of the people who she is leading
astray through her scandal it is in
their best interest it is for their own
good that archbishop core de leone is
saying you cannot receive holy communion
until you
until you
repent until you go to confession
confess your sins receive absolution
then you can do it again this is also
one such welcome courage finally we're
seeing courage from from
some bishops there's some good bishops
but a lot of bishops have been showing a
lot of cowardice here so now the
question is
what about joe biden
what about the other
so-called catholic politicians who tout
their catholicism but then contradict
the teachings of the church will the
other bishops stand up and do what's
right i certainly hope so
the libs are
furious that a catholic bishop is doing
his job
with regard to nancy pelosi keeping her
from receiving holy communion that is
the bishop's job it's his obligation if
the bishop doesn't do that he's going to
have to answer for that someday because
he will be neglecting his job and
allowing his flock to go astray and lead
one another astray the libs are furious
that the bishop is doing this
aoc
has has just suggested that this is a
not just cordelione not just the pelosi
issue but the outlawing of abortion
generally is a grave threat to religious
freedom
people who say oh but you're you know
your
your harming a life i believe this is
life well some religions don't
so how about that
our jewish brothers and f and sisters
they are able to have an abortion
according to their faith you know
there are so many faiths
that
do not have the same definition of life
as
fundamentalist christians
and so
we how what about their rights
what about their right to exercise their
faith
it's ridiculous
and it is it's it is theocratic it's
authoritarian
it is wrong
it's ridiculous it's theocratic it's a
it's wrong what what aoc has said
as in terms of factual statements is
wrong the idea that judaism just totally
permits abortion is completely made up
it's nonsense
the jewish view of abortion is slightly
different than the christian view of
abortion that's true
but
her idea here that it's part of the
jewish faith to commit abortions is just
ridiculous there was a
a sign that someone was holding at a
pro-abortion rally that said abortion is
a jewish value i thought whoa cooler
with the anti-semitism here folks all
right that's what are you talking about
abortion is a jewish value
that's that is a smear of the jewish
people first of all it's not true
and second of all second of all
you do not have a right to do whatever
you want
because you say your religion tells you
to
some religions
aoc's comments about judaism
nonsense her comments about christianity
notice she says only fundamentalist
christians oppose abortion that's not
true christians oppose abortion
if you
support abortion you are violating your
christian faith and you call yourself a
christian you are violating the faith
you are speaking in a way that is
heterodox and heretical and you need to
be corrected but let's go beyond
christianity and judaism some religions
practice virgin sacrifice
some religions practice ritual
cannibalism
many of the
religions of the americas before the
european christians got here practiced
sacrifice of virgins practiced ritual
cannibalism and so is that is it a
violation
of religious liberty to say now in the
united states in the year of our lord
2022 you are not allowed to slaughter
babies and eat them
is that a violation you're not allowed
to slaughter virgins on altars is that a
violation of religious liberty
in a way it is
in a way to give aoc her due yes you are
telling certain religious groups that
you're not allowed to do things
religious liberties such as it is is
limited
it doesn't mean that you can just do
whatever you want to do there are guard
rails there are standards okay
the whole concept of religious liberty
arises in a very specific
religious context namely out of
protestant christianity
so that's the context here that those
are the guardrails when religious
liberty was first being proposed by the
liberal thinkers
no one ever had any thought that you
could no one had any thought that we
would tolerate atheists let alone people
committing human sacrifice let alone
people just doing whatever they want in
the name of religious liberty no that's
not what it means that's not what the
term means philosophically that's not
what the term means historically it's
just nonsense to quote aoc it's
ridiculous
it's totally ridiculous right now go to
epicwill.com
promo code knowles okay if you
god forbid something happened to you
right now what would happen to your
stuff what would happen to your property
what would happen to your kids
would would your kids be raised in
accordance with what you believe the way
that you well if you don't have a will
right now you don't really have a say in
any of that okay
let that sink in
let that sink in no say in not just the
future your stuff the future your
business is the future of your kids if
you're single you think you don't need a
will you could not possibly be more
wrong a will allows you to establish
advanced directive and medical power of
attorney you really want to leave the
burden of deciding huh do i do i keep
this person on life support do i take
them off life support you want to leave
that to one of your friends or family
members you don't want to communicate
what you really want come on get it done
do the responsible thing if you haven't
made one yet you're not alone i just
finished my own will a couple of weeks
ago we're making it easy for you at
epicwill.com when you use promo code
knowles you can go it takes a very short
amount of time you get all of your
affairs in order they are partnering
with us at the daily wire taking care of
us protecting our staff and families let
them protect yours epicwhell.com promo
code noel secure your future in as
little as five minutes with a complete
package starting at 119 bucks when you
use promo code knowles you'll save 10
epic will.com the most important five
minutes you will spend today i'm glad
you liked that video i liked it too i
liked being here with you to be seen by
you if you want to get more videos
you've got to subscribe ring the click
the like the bell the subscribe whatever
you got to do subscribe get the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch your google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
you